um i'm good to start whenever okay great
yeah so thanks everyone for uh coming
back to the last session of the the the
or i should say the last talk of the
morning session and so yeah we're very
happy to have mark longhta uh visiting
us to virtually to tell us about his
work on uh general game theoretic
multi-agent rl so i'll let mark take it
away
yeah thanks a lot for the invitation
it's it's really refreshing to see
a lot of people in the same room i i
can't wait to get back to in person
conferences um and yeah thanks a lot for
inviting me um looks like a great
workshop i really wish i could be there
in person and it's making me want to go
back to conferences i can't wait
um okay so i'm going to talk to you
today uh about
a number of uh like collaborations i've
been involved in i've been really lucky
to be um have a position where i get to
work with a lot of amazing people like
all the time and so i'm very grateful uh
for all their help and all their
influence in this uh most of the stuff
i'll talk about is really like
uh
work that has been done primarily by not
myself
um so a little bit of motivation and
please bear with me it's going to be a
very high level talk
but
i guess i want to motivate i want i'm
hoping that i can influence
you to think about a problem that i care
a lot about
uh and here's the main research research
question i have
um so is there a single objective that
learning agents should optimize in
general multi-agent systems let me
unpack that a little bit so by learning
agents i mean in the rl sense so i want
them to be like distributed or or
decentralized um
in the by general i mean not necessary i
don't want a special case
uh you know the competitive or the
cooperative scenario and have different
algorithms right i'm looking for one
general algorithm
and here by should what i mean is i want
to adopt like the prescriptive view of
multi-agent rl so like we're the
algorithm designers we would like to be
able to put an algorithm on an agent
place it into a multi-agent system and
be
uh convinced that we're doing the right
thing like we are putting the right
algorithm on the agent for
you know reasons that we can justify
okay so i've been largely inspired by
the two-player zero-sum setting i think
it's been like uh you know there's been
a lot of impressive results in the
community uh that has really driven ai
and the progress of of ai has really
been driven by these like large-scale
applications and if you look at them
like a lot of these um
real milestones in ai have been uh
showcasing like how well
um
uh an an agent or a or a strategy can
play in a two players or some case even
from the start of ai
like uh samuel looking into checkers
there
but but really a lot of these uh
kind of silently benefit from uh the
mini max there
and so what i want to talk to you about
a little bit is how can we take all of
that success a lot a lot of which by the
way has been driven by game theory
and you know port it over into the more
general piece
so here's some thought questions um that
will guide the talk um
how can i tell if a chess program
is superhuman so
i think that one's relatively
straightforward like we we
kind of
we all agree on who the best chess
person is we can play our agents against
that chess person we can assume
mostly safely that the results are going
to be transitive and so i think we can
answer that question fairly well but
then
like let's take this a step further what
does it mean to be super human iterated
prisoners alone
um i think that's a little less clear um
how you would measure that
i think it's largely dependent on the
population that they're playing against
and so
uh you know what do you mean do you mean
uh in
for a single population if so what does
should that population be okay like all
the players on the on the planet like
but then you have questions like uh okay
well then what kind of distribution do
you like they play each other with and
and so on um at the very least it's less
clear
this is the one i think that's driven
driving my research uh now are my
interests which is we have a rock paper
scissors competition that has been uh
ran
many years ago now
but
when you look at the entrance and the
participants the winner is not what the
game theoretic optimal uh is like it's
not the equilibrium bond
so
what
why why is that the case
so i want to kind of think about that a
bit more and and explore that
okay before i before i get into um
like suggesting new methods for uh the
general case let's take a look at what i
mean by game theoretic rl in uh
in the two player zero so mostly
inspired by the two players zero some
cases
in the last few years in competitive uh
game theoretic model there's been kind
of two streams
there's one based on uh fictitious play
or kind of like the best response stream
and then there's a regret minimization
stream so i'll just give you like a
quick overview i'll talk a bit about
both let's talk about the best response
stream first the best response stream is
mostly inspired by classical algorithm
called fictitious play where players
start with like some arbitrary strategy
and they iteratively produce
best responses
to the uniform distribution over the the
land the other players iterates
so for example in a game of rock paper
scissors you can start with a player can
start with the arbitrary strategy rock
and playing against rock you would
achieve a utility of zero and you can
ask okay what is the best response to
rock well it's paper
and then both players would add the
paper strategy so they're set and then
they would say okay well what is the
best response to
mixing equally across rock and paper
and they would add paper again
and now paper is overweighted in this
population so
what's the best response to the uniform
distribution over these three strategies
again they're scissors paper is still
overweighted so you would add scissors
again
and uh so on
now what you're seeing
is we're building kind of like a small
game
uh and we're responding each one of
these players is kind of responding to
the uniform distribution over the last
players or the other players strategies
you could do something a little more uh
clever right so instead of responding to
a uniform distribution we can treat this
little thing here as a meta game and we
can say well what's the nash equilibrium
in this meta game and there's one the
pure paper paper equilibrium
and we could say well now we're going to
add uh the scissors strategy because
it's the best response to that uh
distribution
and so this is called double oracle and
it's it's driven um
fictitiously and double or double oracle
together have driven
uh a number of uh multi-agent rl
uh algorithms that have been used in the
in in
in the game theoretic sense
um so i'm going to talk about a bit
about one because uh we extended this to
the more general setting
um
so you can take this metagame uh idea
where we're building up
uh like this metagame through like
repeated best responses and you you can
think that each player has like a set of
policies instead of a set of actions set
of strategies or policies um and you can
you can build up a metagame this
metagame here m
and you can look at you know how well
like what's the expected value that each
of those policies get when you play them
against each other by using some kind of
simulations
and then you can build up uh this meta
tensor and you can take you can think of
this meta tensor as a game like it's an
empirical game
and you can apply some kind of meta
solver to it like nash equilibrium is
just one example
and out pops from your metasol for a
distribution over policies that you
should play
and what's nice about this setup is that
it kind of offload it separates these
two steps
the game theoretic reasoning is done at
the meta stage
and then uh what you do in the second
step is your computer best response and
you can offload that um to like uh you
can consider that a single agent rl
problem now because all of the other
players are fixed
and so you can just you know solve that
with your favorite uh deep reinforcement
learning
and so that's kind of nice and it
you kind of get a nice
scale for for free in some sense because
a lot of effort has been put
into the deep rl circles about how to
you know scale these algorithms to large
games
um
and so
but the problem i mean the main this has
been inspired by the two-player zero-sum
setting so how are we going to extend
this uh outside of that setting
so let me tell you i'm going to tell you
about how we did this
using correlated equilibrium so let me
just give a quick intro to correlated
equilibrium
correlated equilibrium is a more
general
solution concept than nash
it's it's not a factorized it's it's not
two strategies it's not a pair of
strategies that are factorizable
it's a distribution over the or the
joints policy space so here's an example
you can think of it as a recommender
recommender
suggests some distribution or samples
some recommendations from a distribution
and each player sees their part of that
recommendation so the players each know
what that distribution is
and if the players individually do not
have incentive to deviate from
the recommendations they receive
then uh you say that the
the the players are in correlated
equilibrium and there's an associated
solution concept called
course-correlated equilibrium that is
essentially the same
except the players don't see the
recommendations themselves right they
only see the distribution
um
and so those are two related equilibrium
concepts
that we can
talk about when
we want to try and
generalize these algorithms to the
to the to the more general setting
outside of two players or so
and so
this is a
work that i want to talk about where we
do exactly that so first of all why
correlate equilibrium
um they're retractable uh they're easy
while they're in a computational sense
easier to compute the nash kilogram um
it's a it forms a convex space
um in some sense it it is exactly
um addressing the coordination problem
because
this mediator is essentially telling the
agents how to coordinate and it's
principled it's been it's been studied
in game theory for a long time
so we're not going to take any
correlated equilibrium we're going to
look at a specific we we proposed a
specific one
called maximum
gini correlated equilibrium and this
gene we use this gini impurity metric
so when you're solving for correlated
equilibria
you can
you have to decide on an objective
of some form because the correlated
equilibrium if you look if you try to
solve for one if you build an
optimization problem to find one
there there's a set of constraints you
need to satisfy
but then there's an objective like for
example if you want to find the maximum
welfare one your objective uh would be
to maximize the sum of the player
utilities um one alternative uh is and
which has nice properties and
reinforcement learning in particular
is uh you can think of like a maximum
entropy um
correlated equilibrium and so this ginny
impurity uh is
is inspired by entropy it's related it's
an instance of a silas entropy
and uh
except it's it's like uh well it's
slightly easier to work with you there's
a quadratic program that could be
um formulated and you can solve uh
office using off-the-shelf solvers
um but in some sense you could you could
really just think of it as a
form of entry
um what's neat is
there's a unique solution
that always exists
and
this solver finds it so that's kind of
nice
because you're not guaranteed if you
look for a correlated equilibrium you're
not guaranteed to find one that's unique
even if you're maximizing welfare
um
and yeah like i said before there's like
maximum entropy has nice benefits when
you're applying
uh this in a reinforcement learning
learning context because there's some
kind of implicit um like exploration
that that happens
um
okay so
the the application to psro is rather
straightforward like we just essentially
take them in a solver and you compute
for a correlated equilibrium instead of
a instead of a nash or something else
so i'm just putting the
pseudo code here there's nothing really
like
complicated
the
what's nice is you can show
the resulting algorithm
just like in its two players or some uh
equivalent
or analog i should say is uh computes a
correlated equilibrium or course
correlated
is guaranteed to compute a correlated
equilibrium or coarse correlated
equilibrium
um so we verified this empirically and
what's what's interesting on the
empirical side
is how many different variants of these
uh correlated equilibrium solvers you
can have
and so mainly what we did here so we
tried it on a competitive game
a purely cooperative game and a mixed
game
um and what you can see
first of all we we see that this maximum
jenny actually
produces good solution
solutions uh compared to the meta
solvers like the classical meta solvers
which can sometimes get stuck
it has the desired effect
the desired exploration effect that we
suspected it would at least in the case
of
cooperative settings
um like this tradecom is like a kind of
a small emergent communication domain uh
signaling game you can kind of think of
it as where
like exploration is really important
because you're trying to find like the
maximum it's like a needle in a haystack
style problems like a coordination game
essentially
um
and we tried it in a game that has been
previously analyzed uh in this setting
like sheriff so farina and colleagues um
have a paper that characterized like the
the the correlated equilibrium landscape
here and what's kind of neat is that all
these these different
uh parametrizations of these uh
correlated equilibria uh
lend like lead to different looking uh
convergence graphs and uh utility sums
um
and uh and and the maximum jenny one
tends to do quite well and in fact it
actually finds the maximum welfare one
at least in the ones that we've tried uh
quite often
okay so that was a very like
quick tour do i still have everybody i
don't mean i want to do these sound one
of these sound checks now
dylan are you still there uh yes yeah uh
yeah it looks good so far yep
okay thanks
um
okay so i'm going to move now to the
regret minimization stream which will be
um equally quickly and
presented at a high level
um
so what do we do in the regret
minimization side um
we have uh we have the setting where
we're in self play
i'm going to give you a quick example
where the row player is the one that's
going to be regret minimizing
the column player is going to have a
distribution over there's a fixed
distribution over the strategies so
let's say 20 40 40 again
in rock paper scissors
um and you can ask yourself okay well i
can i can play with some kind of a
baseline policy like the uniform policy
if i play with the uniform policy
against this other one
i would get a utility of zero
now i can go and i can iterate over each
one of my actions
and ask myself how much would i have
preferred to have played rock like how
much do i regret not playing entirely
wrong
and you can compare it to the value that
your baseline policy would get and you
could do this over each one of your
actions
and you can compute a regret
and there's this nice regret matching
algorithm that lets you that
that says basically turn your policy
into the positive portion
or normalize over the positive
the yeah the positive cumulative regret
and turn that into a new policy to play
from there
so that's just a quick example of one
particular regret minimizing strategy
called regret matching
when you do this from one player's
perspective perspective when you do this
uh
in self-play both players are going to
do
uh the same are going to have the same
algorithm and they're both going to be
minimizing regret
now
um
this has been amazingly successful in
poker ai specifically because of this uh
counterfactual regret minimization
algorithm but but the idea goes as
follows like both players start out
with uh
some arbitrary policy
and they produce iterates
right um in cell play so each player is
using like some kind of regret
minimizing policy and the average policy
that they compute
is going to be an approximate nash
equilibrium in in two players
and what's really neat is that okay i
mean what makes this possible in poker
is specifically the counterfactual
regret formulation
which is to take it takes essentially
takes regret match it allows you to do
regret matching
but at each information state completely
separately
and the combination of those like
individual regret minimizers
uh minimizes the overall regret
so so again this has been like the state
of the art in poker ai for the past 15
years um
so
cfr is to poker i think what you know
mini max was suggest
um we're you know we're seeing like the
basic algorithm has been
uh iterated uh many times now and we we
essentially have like a lot of different
variants of of cfr um
so
this is a
you know this is what makes it all
possible to bring to the sequential
setting and the the critical part of cfr
is the definition of the value
there's a special definition of the
value called the counterfactual value
um
and that's what allows the cfr theorem
uh to work to go through so that you can
so what you're doing is you're employing
this recruitment regret matching at each
information state on this like um
yeah
notion of counterfactual value instead
of the normal kind of like expected
return
um
okay but now what i want to do is like i
said
at least in the poker world right we've
we've used this as a tool for computing
like approximate equilibria
but i want to take a step back for a
second drink some water first
and um
and maybe switch the situation around
so now i want to think of instead of
starting out with arbiter's arbitrary
policies and then iterating to produce
something i want to think about it as
from the agent's perspective
so each one of these agents is actually
looking back over its like course of
play and it's asking itself how could i
have changed my policy or how much do i
regret not changing
my entire policy over that period
right it's the same problem but it's
looking at it in the other direction
that or the direction that we're not
used to
all right not used to from the game's uh
community anyway
and if you look at just one agent this
is really starting to look a lot more
like
standard reinforcement right the agent
is really just in this environment
except it's a specialized environment
right it's not just any environment it's
an environment where other agents are
acting but not only
their acting um they are influencing um
the the decisions that this agent i
would make
um because they are part of the
environment so
so you know this is
well known of course um we have an agent
we have a paper on this that we call the
hindsight and sequential rationality of
correlated play and i'll tell you a
little bit about this paper um because
what's really interesting about uh the
environment that you set up here is the
fact that uh
what these agents are doing are
correlated they're essentially
creating a correlation device
through self-play
um so the question we come back to now
is well what does what does that mean
about what they're converging to
um can we bring back correlated
equilibrium and the answer is mostly yes
um
i will mostly skip this because it's
well known but i but it's an important
part of the motivation so
it's it's well known that
if you put a number of no regret
minimizers no external regret minimizers
into an environment
that
and they produce policy iterates
you can take a uniform distribution over
the joint policies that they produce
and that
is approaching a course-correlated
equilibrium and that's kind of amazing
when you think about it like if you just
look at the two definitions they're
essentially like equivalent um
and
that's really neat because they're
correlating in an interesting way um
uh and and so and what that means is you
can kind of think of
you know the thing that they're
producing together if you have uniform
distribution over that
that
if you were to just sample
one of those policies those joint
policies and consider that to be a
recommendation to each player
then
they are producing a course-correlated
equilibrium together so
what's really neat about that is that
cfr
has has
uh you know just been sitting there
minimizing external regret since 2008
but not many people asked you know what
are the um
like what are the implications of this
we just kind of knew that by definition
they're producing a sequence that
corresponds to of course correlated
equilibria now over the last few years
there's been a lot more interest about
the sequential case so that when i say
course correlated equilibrium i just
mean
uh in in this
mostly like normal form interpretation
where you sample a policy and then the
recommendation is the entire policy
right so what about the sequential case
so there's been a lot of excitement here
and i don't have time to cover
everything i will just say a little bit
about what i think is the most
interesting part of like this one paper
that i highlighted
so
to be able to say that i need to say a
little bit about how these
correlated equilibria get extended to
the sequential case
so the classic one is called extensive
form correlated equilibrium
and it's
it's different from a correlated
equilibrium in that
uh the agents get recommendations at
each step
right
and what they can do
uh
what they can decide to do is either
follow or deviate
and if they deviate in this case it's a
lot more complicated right because you
can't just deviate to another
you deviate to
by choosing another action but then you
have to
play like play the entire sub game
completely different
completely differently as well and so
any agent that has no incentive to
deviate from the sequence of
recommendations
is said to be uh in an extensive form
correlated equilibria and again there's
the equivalent one
where you don't get to see the
recommendations but the recommendations
are still made that's called an efcc
um and so one thing so we called this
causal in our paper and this is like a
set the deviation types that we consider
that lead to these type of equilibria
are called causal equilibria
and we call them causal because
there's an assumption that the sequence
of actions are being followed
from top to bottom
okay can i do another quick sound check
dylan
uh yep working good so far okay i'm
getting messages from an external source
so it's like oh this could be people
telling me that i've dropped oh yeah i
was gonna say well we could hear the
notification but other than that yeah
yeah
okay um
okay so
so i was just saying this is um
these are causal we call these causal
because we formulate them as triggers so
like
the agent is at a decision point
and then
there's a trigger action
or a trigger information set action pair
that they would have to say i have
incentive to deviate at this point to go
off and play this entire strategy but
importantly it rests on the assumption
that the sequence of actions up to that
point were followed like this black
zigzag line i have
um
it's imp then that's why we call them
causal
okay i have one last thing to say on
this which is
something that was driving us that one
question we were curious about and there
was like a whole chain of emails
among a number of different people where
we were arguing back and forth and we
switched our opinions several times
about whether cfr computed
or converged to an extensive form course
correlated equilibrium
and the answer is it doesn't
and it's uh so then ef's the set of efcc
and the deviation types that you need to
satisfy to minimize or minimize regret
over to compute these are different than
the ones that
cfr does and the reason for that we came
up with a counter example
and the reason for that is that the
definition of the character factual
value necessarily
involves changing the distribution
of the policy that you took during that
recommendation sequence
i know that's very like high level and i
i wish i had more time to go into detail
uh
and so i guess it's hard to appreciate
but it it was very interesting to us
because it seemed
at first to be an obvious thing that it
should converge to in the fcc
and what this resulted in was basically
a paper that tried to characterize the
uh the different deviation types
uh and associated uh equilibria that
arise in self-play so this is our paper
um there is a cool algorithm that came
out of all this actually that
called extensive form regret
minimization and i will not cover it but
amy will and in fact she'll talk about
it also in the context of fire regret
minimization uh tomorrow so if you're
interested in these ideas or if you want
to know more than i i covered here in
this very little amount of time uh
please attend amy's talk she was
instrumental in in this world
um okay so i will just end with
um so what
or
what now um
what are the
so really i just gave an ex i gave kind
of an overview of like the the type of
game theoretic approaches we're taking
to reinforcement learning
and i promised or at least i started
with i care about the general case and i
want to get to the general case and i
told you mostly methods that were
inspired by the zero sum case
and that's because i do feel like we can
bring over a lot of the tools from game
theory to analyze and to um and to
inspire our algorithms into in the
general case
the problem with the ones that i've
shown you so far well there's two
problems and the jps row has a major
problem because it's completely
centralized in the sense that it's going
to compute exactly this distribution
which is over the joint policy space and
you can interpret it in the prescriptive
way that there's a mediator handing you
these
um
in the regret minimization stream
there's kind of a similar problem in the
sense that like the convergence
guarantees that we've been showing
hold hold for the case of self play
where you make this assumption that the
other algorithms are playing the same uh
or minimizing the same type of regret
that you are
um
so really we haven't achieved you know
this decentralized setup that i kind of
set up or this
you know this problem that i tried to
set up
but but now how am i thinking okay so
but how do we address these
the way i'm thinking about it now and
i'm i'm maybe i will just leave you with
this open question is is to try and
combine is is there something in the
combined stream here that we can that we
can do
um
and the way i'm thinking about it now is
that we have like this agent and this
agent is just learning
and maybe it's based on no regret i you
know i i feel like uh that's a good
start
um but it has the kind of best response
ideas in it
in that we can create some kind of
population ahead of time you know this
is the training grounds right this is
the agents like
you know um where he spends most of his
life he or she spends most of its
lifetime like learning how to play
against other types of agents and maybe
this is heuristically chosen right or
maybe it's not um maybe there's also um
like maybe we freeze this agent at
certain time points during its life and
we throw it into the training population
with it but then the the idea is that it
keeps going at test time it moves over
and it just keeps learning it keeps
employing its no regret algorithm and we
haven't had to switch anything major
um
and and i feel like this is combining a
lot
i feel like we can combine what we've
learned about these two separate streams
into this kind of
like
like meta agent or mega agent i'm not
sure what to call it so i'm going to
leave you with that main open question
i'm sorry that i don't have any concrete
answers for this yet but
i hope i will in the next year or two um
and uh
that's it that's my time
thanks
thanks a lot
any questions see were there any
questions
oh yeah it looks like hyping has a
question
is there any theory for the double or
recoil reason
yeah
yes and it's just not very good i mean
the bit so okay so
what i can say about the basic double
oracle algorithm i'm trying to get to
the start but i don't know how much that
makes sense um
is that
uh there's basically just an asymptotic
argument for the basic algorithm
so um
you know for the uh maybe for the
obvious reasons it will approach
an equilibrium because eventually it's
going to expand its entire strategy
space
we do have
um by we i should say it's mostly
stephen mckiller but
several collaborators of his as well
have an algorithm
that does have slightly actually okay i
should i'd say we're not the only ones
who have this
there's
at least two other algorithms that have
better i would say convergence
guarantees one is called
one combines it actually with no regret
and the authors are failing me now um
but
i will point you to it if you send me an
email the other one i know about is our
recent paper hours that shows and
this this is like modular better
convergence which is
uh
when combined with ps4 or double oracle
in in general can actually
increase the exploitability
from iteration to iteration in the in
the full game
whereas uh
we can yeah we have a new way of doing a
meta solver that actually
makes sure that that's not the case so
it's always strictly going down in the
full game that doesn't really answer
your question i don't think um because
you were asking about double oracle um
i think yeah i think that's
that's my that's the extent to which i
unders that i i'm familiar with
like the double or okay
thanks
but i think there's like
yeah i think that
there's right there's lots of
opportunities there to to to take that
question and do research because i think
we mostly don't know the answer
well it looks like we've got another
question from kevin
hey mark could you thank you
yeah nice to see you uh could you go to
the last slide in the best response um
stream
early on
i
you're using the genie thing to uh
all right
like the in the jps row this guy
maybe can you tell me um
yeah
so
so i guess
i was left confused by
this result um why is this better than
finding a correlated equilibrium just
based on welfare directly and it seems
like all of the advantages that you're
showing here would also be shared by by
just finding the maximum welfare
correlated equilibrium and that would be
an lp instead of a qp
yeah so the the the one thing actually
luke
kind of made this nice diagram so like
okay so this is the polytope of the ce
space for this small game here of i
think you call it traffic lights
and so this little orange line here i
don't know if you're seeing my cursor
but there's a line between like
gw and wg
that is the
like span of maximum welfare cces
so
what the ginny one does is it maximizes
like you can think of it as entropy
um so it's going to find the one that's
maximally mixing between those and this
actually has a nice effect in the rl
setting in particular
um because you don't get stuck um like
you don't choose one that is uh you know
that has zero weight
on um
you know like
it doesn't only choose for example wg
right and so when you're producing
iterates for the next iteration
um you have you have
positive probability in selecting uh
something that is not wg
right
um
i mean it yeah to go down to like so i
mean your question is like about
complexity right so like going from
linear to quadratic or suddenly the
other way
um
it's a good question in terms of like
okay does that account for the fact that
you go from quadratic program to linear
program
don't know that is a very good question
i do feel like even if you if you try to
bring this into the land where you do rl
with approximation that that is going to
get even worse that problem is going to
get worse where you
where you want the entropy
um
but yeah it's mostly an empirical answer
does that make sense though like
there's a
comment in the chat that's kind of maybe
getting it a partial answer something
about fairness which i think is what
mark might have been alluding to also
yeah that makes us
well kevin didn't see the comments in
the chat so
maybe i can't get to the chat
ah
oh wait a second i'm trying to find the
chat yeah sorry no the comment in the
chat was just uh yeah was the term gd
used to reflect uh some kind of desire
for fairness across players
oh possibly i actually don't know the
roots of the ginny uh impurity but it
comes from
it's used in like classification and
decision trees
uh so it's like a known version as far
as i know of
solace entropy
uh so i don't know if that answers the
question
it doesn't yeah is that on oh right okay
it does measure inequality so maybe
that's what the question was referring
to
oh it's like wealth inequality for
example
like when the income distribution is
very unequal oh right yeah um yeah but
in this example
you don't end up with wg all the time
sometimes your wg sometimes your gw so
everybody gets to go through the traffic
light
right
right you're not yeah and yeah
that's that's exact that's kind of the
motivation behind the maximum genie
right
is to exactly if you have a maximum
welfare or if you even have just any
space between two joint policies pick
the one that maximizes the
uh
the like entropy
so mark i have another question which is
that your
whole discussion was you know you have
this very intriguing question that you
posed for all of us that you thought you
might have an answer to in a year or two
i'm really looking forward to that
that's very short-term horizon
but then your whole talk was about
correlated equilibrium like lots of
different varieties of correlated
equilibrium but are you suggesting that
maybe like that's a direction that we
should be thinking of when we're trying
to answer that intriguing question
yeah that's a very good question i mean
this is exactly what's been
on my mind like daily for the since we
started talking about it right
so okay here's my
i could talk about this for hours and i
wish i was there because i would love to
actually do that i will give my short
version of the of this question it's
like
um as you as okay so so when you come
and i'll i'll bring up the question
which is when you come with this mission
about okay now we're going to take these
game theoretical methods outside of two
player zero sum
where do you go right
and if you start by reading papers and
looking at the literature like you
inevitably find your way to correlated
equilibrium actually there's there's two
kind of two sides to that like it's not
only that you find yourself to
correlated equilibria but the fact that
these no regret minimizers
produce cces um in self-play
it even feels more relevant to talk
about correlated equilibrium because
there's a real sense in which like
correlation over the actual play is
happening like correlation in the real
like formal for like definition of
correlation
so
i'm not really tied to like
correlated equilibria being like the
uh or some variant of correlated to be
the the answer
to how to get us there but i think at
the very least it's it's
it's really important um
because there's this strong time between
what happens in self-play
and uh
uh like uh the concept of the correlated
equilibrium
um
so so yes i don't know i i i largely
don't know but um i'm not giving up on
correlated equilibrium
um
so i so like what what you know what
algorithm
like for example
um what would we put on this agent
um
like like i guess efr would be the first
thing i would that we should try
um
and then what yeah how we can
instantiate like i'm really curious
right about how
maybe maybe the even longer version if i
had longer time to talk about this and i
want to talk to you about it of course
is
uh if we take these deviation types and
we have players playing different
um like like minimizing regret with
respect to different deviation types
then what can we say about the result of
their play
i i don't have the answer to that and so
if if there's anything we can say about
that
then i'm even more on board for
you know
keeping the correlation
um
but sorry that that's a long-winded
non-answer
uh let's see uh maybe we can take one
last question if there are if there
are any more questions
all right uh maybe we'll stop there then
uh let's let me give mark another round
of applause
[Applause]
thank you
so thanks again mark uh it was really
thought provoking talk and uh i'm glad
i'm glad you were able to drop in
um why don't we go ahead and uh break
for lunch but yeah i hope to see
everyone back at two for the afternoon
session i think we have a bunch of
fun talks planned so see you there
[Music]
hi mark